- I mean it was an escalation,
because you had not just
you know, one person,
Trump or his supporters
being ghosted
or deplatformed but you
had 16 million Parler users
or whatever it is.
99.9% of whom never did
anything wrong you know?
And that was a diminishment
of their free speech rights.
It was also I think unjustified,
if the justification for
that was that Parler was used
in the planning of the
events of January 6th,
it was clearly a scapegoating
because we now have
FBI charging documents
have come out.
- Yeah.
- 226 cases, the
social networking site
that was used 10x more than
all the others was Facebook.
You know Parler was used
one tenth of the amount
that Facebook was but,
Parler was you know, was
sort of an easy target
to sort of scapegoat for that.
(calm music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is the former COO of PayPal,
an angel investor in such
companies as Facebook,
Uber and SpaceX.
The founder of Craft
Ventures and a cohost
of the the All-In Podcast.
David Sacks, welcome
to The Rubin Report.
- Great to be here.
- I'm glad to have you.
You know when I was looking
through all your bios
and Wikipedia which I'm
sure is all perfectly true
and all that good stuff,
there's a lot of stuff
I could've pulled
there for the bio
and I was thinking for my
young audience watching this,
like basically being a
part of all of those things
kind of seems like the
coolest thing possible.
So how does somebody
get into all of that?
- Yeah I mean I was lucky
to graduate Stanford in 1994
which was the year
before the internet
really kind of took off
and I was lucky enough
to meet Peter Thiel
when I was there
and we collaborated together on,
you know we both worked
on the student newspaper,
the sort of conservative
libertarian student newspaper
that Peter founded
and then we ended up
writing a book together
and he recruited me
years later to join
PayPal and you know,
actually he thought I had
missed the whole internet thing
and then I got a call
from Peter in 1999
and he told me about this
company he was creating
and you know, that company
went on to become PayPal
and he recruited
me to be the COO.
- Do you think?
- So yeah,
that's how I got into it.
- Yeah do you think
Peter or you or Elon,
like did anyone realize
what any of this stuff
was gonna become or just
when it's unfolding,
you just kind of run with
it and see what happens?
- You know, it, at the time,
we sort of knew
on a certain level
that it was changing the world.
Like at PayPal we
had this user counter
that would track the user growth
and we called it the
World Domination Index.
So on a certain level
we kind of you know,
thought it was
taking over the world
but on another level we
didn't quite you know,
understand it.
It felt a little bit like
fantasy or something.
So yeah, it was like you know,
it definitely operated
on both levels.
- Yeah, how much of PayPal
was just trying to get people
to like understand you
could do things differently.
I literally remember the
first time I saw PayPal,
I had moved into a new apartment
with a couple of roommates,
I was a struggling comic,
I barely had any money
and one of my
roommates said to me,
you've gotta pay me on
PayPal for the rent and I,
I didn't even know
what that meant.
Like the idea that I
could link a bank account
to something online
and I don't even
think we had WiFi yet.
It was still wire to wall.
Just getting people to
understand there's new ways
of doing things, how
much of it is just that?
- A big part of it and then
the other big part of it
was just making it really
easy to actually do it.
So you know we, it's
a lot easier now.
We didn't have all
the tools you know,
that we have now 20 years ago
and so just getting the
product to be super simple
so you could put it
in an email address,
put it in your
credit card number
and it would send the money
and then you'd get it,
be able to take it
to your bank account.
I mean it sounds really
easy but you know,
there's all this
friction in the way
that had to be removed
and I think part of the
reason why we're successful
is we were able just to
make it incredibly simple.
- Yeah so you mentioned
"The Diversity Myth"
and I've talked to
Peter on the show
and you guys wrote
this book, 1995.
In essence you wrote
this at Stanford.
You guys kind of predicted
everything that was happening,
that's happening right now.
Like really the idea that
sort of the diversity
of immutable characteristics
would matter more than
the diversity of thought
which we now see just rampaging
through all our businesses
and institutions
and the political
sphere and everything.
How did you guys see it coming?
We had been you know,
writing on the Stanford Revue
and Stanford was sort
of the epicenter.
That there was a famous protest
in 1988 where Jesse Jackson
led a mob that was chanting,
"Hey hey, ho ho, western
culture's gotta go."
So Stanford was sort
of the epicenter
for a lot of that stuff and
so we were writing about it
as student journalists in a way
and that book was an extension
of the student
journalism we had done.
You know, looking back,
I mean I was a teenager
when we wrote a lot of that.
I wouldn't necessarily
make all the same arguments
the same way that
I did back then
but I do think we were
ahead of the curve
in realizing you know, this,
this growing illiberalism.
This sort of
political correctness,
now it's called cancel
culture where you know,
we're putting restrictions
on people's ability to speak
and to think and to
express themselves in ways
that I think would've been,
that certainly you
know, 1960s liberals
wouldn't have you know,
wouldn't have supported
and so you know, I never
actually saw myself
as a conservative.
I saw myself as more of
like a 1960s-style liberal
who believed in free
speech and you know,
a colorblind society.
- I know the feeling man.
- I think we're on a
similar journey here.
- Yeah.
- With these issues.
But yeah, I mean it was
the illiberalism on campus
that sort of pushed me to become
more politically
aware and you know,
and that's what
the book was about.
And now really, the
whole country is like,
it was like Andrew
Sullivan says,
we all live on campus now.
- Right, 'cause it's
kind of funny to me.
You guys were writing
about this in 95
and say when I was talking
about some of this stuff,
five years ago.
So you know, 20 years
after you wrote about it,
people kept saying to me,
no no it's just gonna stay
on campuses and when they
get to the real world,
the real world will
show them and no.
- Well those students.
- That did not work out.
- Those students
graduated you know,
and they took those
ideologies into the places
where they went and so you know,
they took them to the,
you know a lot of those
graduates went off
to run school boards or to
run you know, newspapers,
The New York Times
and places like that.
I mean this is, it's a
very elite philosophy
or ideology that's being imposed
and it's coming from
places like Stanford
and other Ivy
League type schools.
- Yeah, so you've
been big on sort
of the three topics that at
least for me at the moment
are my big three topics
which are big tech,
COVID and then
California specifically
'cause I think there's
COVID at a sort of national
and worldwide level
and then California.
So we'll hold that for a moment
but on the big tech stuff,
you know I started
talking about free speech
a couple years ago and
then there was suddenly
this feeling that we were
kind of being censored
but we couldn't figure it out.
Then we started hearing
phrases like shadowbanning
and deboosting and
algorithmic fairness,
all of these things.
And I think one of the things
that people wonder about
is how this all infected all of,
seemingly all of the
big tech companies.
Do you have any theories
on where it sort of started
in there and how it
became so inclusive?
- Yeah, well I think you know,
the technology industry
is primarily based
in Silicon Valley
and most of the people
are pretty liberal
and so there would be
sort of that liberal skew
but for I'd say most of
the evolution of these
big tech companies they saw
themselves as neutral platforms
and they didn't see
themselves as partisans
engaged in a political battle.
They merely wanted
to create the tools
and the platforms for
other people to communicate
and I think something changed,
if I had to sort of
pinpoint when it changed
it would've been around 2016.
You know when Trump got elected.
I think that a lot of big
tech bought into the argument
that they had sort of
caused Trump to be elected
or you know, that
sort of disinformation
had been used through
their platforms
and that that this had resulted
in the election of Trump
and so therefore they could
no longer just be neutral,
they would have to take
corrective measures
to prevent this disinformation
and I think that was sort of
the beginning of it where again
the, I think big tech sort
of bought into this idea.
I think they were
predisposed to buying into it
because they were liberal
but they were never
as partisan as they
subsequently became
over the last few years.
It's not that dissimilar
from I think what happened
with the news industry.
You know there were
people like Brent Bozell,
for years who were doing studies
showing that 90% of
reporters were liberal,
voted Democrat and so on.
But they believed in a
code, a journalistic code
of objectivity or neutrality.
And somehow you know over,
over the last four years,
Trump was perceived
as such a threat that you know,
the media decided that
it was more important
to stop Trump than to
live up to the sort of,
this code of neutrality
and I think something similar
happened in big teach as well.
- Yeah, has it
been tough for you
as someone that isn't
purely a leftist
regardless of how you fully
defined yourself but you're not,
you're clearly not
purely leftist but to
be in San Francisco
and still be around
a lot of that.
I mean right now we know
that a ton of people,
the whole biz, the whole
industry is fleeing to Miami.
Miami is looking
pretty good right now
to have some open conversations.
- Well yeah I mean so, no.
I mean there's been no
reprisals or anything like that
but I do think that people
feel like they can't
say you know, exactly
what they think.
I do think that people
feel uncomfortable
expressing a view that's
not the prevailing,
you know the prevailing
views and so for me,
part of the reason
why I started doing
the All-In Pod and
started speaking out more
is just to show people
that they could speak out.
Because the gap between
what makes sense
and what people feel comfortable
has never been greater.
I mean if you look back on 2020,
I mean just to
name a few issues.
I mean these protracted
lockdowns that you know,
aren't substantiated by science.
I mean they're
just kind of crazy.
The idea of defunding or
abolishing the police.
I mean you can you
know, believe that
we need to have controls on
the use of violence by police
but just to say that we
should just abolish the police
or defund them or to
empty out the jails
which is happening
now in San Francisco.
- We'll get to your
DA in a little bit,
don't worry about that.
- So it's not just for me but
what struck me is not just
like that these ideas
are just so crazy
and sort of off-base but just
that nobody felt comfortable
saying these things
and so I felt
a little bit of an
obligation to speak out more
because you know, economically,
you know if I get canceled I'm
still gonna be fine you know?
I'm not, I'm in
a position where,
I mean I don't know if I can
be canceled but if I can,
you know economically
I'm gonna be fine.
So, so I felt like we need
more people to speak up,
speak out so that
everybody feels comfortable
and they don't feel like
they're just going crazy
if they're you know, not in
favor of defunding the police
or something like that.
- Yeah are you surprised that
in the Silicon Valley world
there weren't more people.
I mean there's plenty of people
that I think have a little
more libertarian approach
to the world.
I think all of you
guys, you like business,
you like competition,
you like capitalism,
all of those things and
there are plenty of people
that are at least somewhat
financially secure
that still are pretty quiet
'cause they'll reach out
to me privately but then
they're like, no no no no,
I'm not gonna go on the show.
- Yeah so it's funny,
the latest episode.
So I do a pod with.
- Yeah.
- The All-In Pod with three
other friends in Silicon Valley.
We all play poker together,
hence the name All-In
and it's sort of a
mix of people across
the political spectrum.
But on the last
episode we were joking
that it was sort of
the red pill episode
because we were talking
about California
and we were talking about
crime in San Francisco,
we were talking the
protracted lockdowns.
We were talking about
the Newsom recall
and pretty much
everybody on the pod,
all four of us were
basically espousing positions
that you could say
were you know, so that,
I don't even know if they
were to the right of center
but they were sort of
you know, red pilled
and so I think there
is kind of now,
I think more of a
willingness of people.
I don't know if it's a
willingness to speak out
but I definitely think
there's a lot more people
who feel the way that we do,
that things have go too far.
And I think part of it is also
that with Trump off the scene
it does depressurize the
situation to some degree
for you know, like some of the.
One or two of the
guys on our pod,
I would describe as having
TDS for sure you know?
And now that he's, that
he's sort of cured of his
Trump derangement
syndrome, he's,
you know he's speaking out
about the DA in San Francisco
as much as anybody.
So yeah, I mean I think that
changes things a little bit.
- Yeah all right, so
before we go too far down
the California thing
and I know you've got
all kinds of issues
with your DA up there
and you have challenged
him to a debate,
we'll see if it actually happens
but I just thought
we could go into
some of the basic
stuff about big tech
that I think people
are confused by.
So you've written a
bunch about Section 230
of The Communications Act.
- Yeah.
- And I thought maybe,
could you just kind of
clean it up for people
because I hear a
lot of people saying
oh Trump should've invoked
230 and now it's too late,
and we should do it,
we shouldn't do it.
But basically in
your Medium article,
you made the argument, it's
a little more nuanced perhaps
than just invoking it.
- Yeah.
- Or getting rid of
it or whatever else.
- Yeah, the call that you're
hearing by conservatives
is that they wanna
repeal Section 230
which is the liability shield
that protects big tech companies
and what that liability
shield does is that
when somebody posts
content on their platforms
that would normally
give rise to liability,
you can only sue the
person who posted it
and not the platform.
So it's a little bit
like the distinction
between a magazine
and a newsstand.
You know, if the magazine
publishes an article
that's defamatory, then
the magazine can be sued
but the newsstand on
which the magazine is sold
cannot be sued.
It did not participate in
the creation of that content,
it merely distributed it.
That was the distinction
that Section 230
sought to establish.
It basically said that
these big tech companies
and really all tech companies.
This doesn't just
apply to the big ones
but to small innovators
as well, they're protected
as long as all they're
doing is distributing.
As long as they're not
creating the content
and I think there's a lot of,
that makes a lot of sense
because you couldn't have
restaurant reviews
on Yelp you know,
if Yelp could be sued
every time you know,
a small business
didn't like the review.
You would have, Reddit
was sued recently
because people in a
comment board lost money
on one of the trades
that was you know,
that was posted
in WallStreetBets.
And so you know,
and so you know,
Gmail maybe would be imperiled
if Google could be sued
every time a crime was
committed using Gmail right?
And so it doesn't make sense
to always hold the tech
platform liable for any content
that the user is posting.
You surely go after
those, those users.
That part of Section
230 which is sort of,
is provision Section
230(c)(1), that still I think
makes a lot of sense and if
you were to get rid of it,
sort of throw the baby
out with the bathwater,
I think you would hurt a
lot of small innovators.
There's a lot of
small tech companies
that rely on that
liability protection
to offer their service.
The problem is, it all
came in with Section (c)(2)
which basically, this is,
it's really interesting.
This is where Congress,
this is where you know,
the road to hell is paved
with good intentions.
What Congress tried to
do in (c)(2) was say
to the big tech
companies, listen,
we don't wanna punish you
for being good Samaritans.
So if you wanna take
down content on your site
because it's pornographic,
it's obscene,
it's excessively violent
or otherwise objectionable,
you can take that down
and we won't hold you
to be a publisher.
You'll still stay say,
you'll stay a newsstand
in our eyes and so you
know, Congress tried to,
Congress was very worried.
This was 1996 when
the Act was passed,
it's called the
Communications Decency Act.
And they were very worried
about smut on the internet
and they were trying
to give tech companies
an incentive or
protection to remove
this type of
objectionable content
without then triggering
liability and so,
but see this is where all
the censorship concern
has now come in.
- Right.
- Because fastforward
15 years later
and big tech companies are
using this very broad term,
otherwise objectionable
to mean content
that they simply don't like.
That you know, politically
they don't like it
and so they now have all
this censorship power
and this is where all
the problem has come in.
This is why you know,
Trump and others
have called for the
repeal of Section 230.
I understand that, the desire.
Because I think the
censorship is wrong
but I just think that we need a,
we need a slightly
different solution.
- Right, so do you have
a sense of what goes on
at the board meetings
of these companies
when they're trying to
make these policies?
Because I think a
lot of people think
and I've tried to get my
audience off this idea
that it's a couple
of guys sitting there
and they all hate conservatives
and the goal is just to
destroy conservatives
'cause I don't think
it's that simple.
I think it's much
more complex than that
but what would be
like a sensible policy
'cause it seems fairly obvious.
You can see it in
Twitter trends.
You know I screencapture
them all the time
and it's very obvious when,
sometimes they're
actually trying
to push a mob towards somebody.
So what would be
a sensible policy
that you think would be
honest and legal I suppose?
- Well I'm pretty happy with
the First Amendment you know?
I think the First Amendment
and then 230 years
of Supreme Court case law
provides us with the standard
and that the Supreme
Court for two centuries
has been wrestling with the
problem of dangerous speech.
I think there's a misconception
that the First Amendment
allows anything
goes, it doesn't.
There are at least nine
categories of speech
that are not protected
by the First Amendment
because they're dangerous.
You cannot yell fire
in a crowded theater,
you cannot incite people
to commit a crime.
You can't engage in fraud.
You know you can't, you
can't defame somebody.
You know fighting
words are illegal.
So there's a lot of
categories of speech
that aren't protected
and most of the speech
that causes social networks
the greatest problems,
they fall into one
of those categories
and so I think it
would be very doable
for them to create a
content moderation policy
that is broadly consistent
with the First Amendment.
Now the reason why I say
broadly is because look,
take defamation for example.
We're not gonna do a
court trial every time
that a user complains that
they're being harassed
by another user okay?
- Right.
- But what we're gonna do is,
we're gonna have a
standard that says that
if a user complains
about another user's post
and that post is
facially defamatory
about that other user
we're gonna take it down
because there are billions
of these social media posts
and we're not gonna
run a trial every time.
But, we're gonna
take our guidelines
from First Amendment case law
and those are basically gonna
be the broad categories.
What we're not gonna do
is create new categories
of speech that are prohibited
because that would appropriate
to the big tech companies,
extraordinary power you know?
- But do you think the problem,
do you think the inherent
problem is that because so much
of the social justice stuff
has now leaked into these
companies that you know,
I can get on board
what you just said.
Most of my audience
can get on board
with what you just
said but they can't
because they've
accepted this ideology
that many ways is just
completely counter to that.
- I think ideology
is very motivating
especially for a lot of
the low level employees
who've banded together
and created pressure
on the leadership, the
management of these companies.
They've created these
campaigns, these boycotts.
There's also pressure
coming from above,
from the Senate
Judiciary Committee
and that Committee
basically, in these hearings,
the people are now, the leading
members of that committee
keep, basically are
telling big tech
on the one hand we
want you to censor more
and on the other, we're
thinking about breaking you up
and so there's a lot
of pressure I think
that big tech is feeling
that if they don't go along
with these policies that
either they're gonna you know,
anger the people above and
that may increase the chances
they get busted up.
Or that they will, you know,
they're gonna upset
sort of this pressure
that's coming from below
from the employees.
I don't think it's a very
good excuse by the way,
I think they should have
more courage and
backbone than that.
I think our commitment
to free speech
should be made of
sterner stuff than that.
- Yeah.
- But I think the reality is
that these companies
are you know,
succumbing to
pressure campaigns.
- What do you think just broadly
about just the amount of
power that they have over us?
Because you mentioned the
First Amendment before,
I don't think the founders
could've ever imagined
that there would basically
be four companies
that in many ways I
think you could argue
are more powerful
than the government.
At least in our day to
day lives at this point.
What do we do about
that amount of power?
- They do have an
extraordinary amount of power
because what happened is the
town square got privatized.
Free speech got digitized,
that caused the town
square to get privatized
and the First Amendment
got euthanized.
You know, because you know,
when the framers
of the Constitution
wrote the First Amendment,
where did you go
for free speech?
There were a multiplicity
of town squares
all over the country, there
were thousands of them.
You could get on the
courthouse steps,
pull out your soapbox.
You could speak and anyone
who wanted to listen
could gather around.
That's why the First
Amendment contains
not just the right
to free speech
but a right to
peacefully assemble.
Well where do people
assemble today?
On these massive social networks
which have gigantic
network effects.
That is where you go to be heard
and if you cannot
express yourself
on one of these social networks,
to what extent do you still
have a free speech right
in this country?
I don't think you
do and what we saw
and what we were seeing you
know, since the election
is that you effectively
have a cartel
of these big tech
companies coming together,
making identical
decisions, deny people
their free speech rights.
And you know, again,
to what extent do
you really have
a First Amendment
right in this country
when the town square
has been privatized
and you've been deplatformed.
- Can you talk a little
bit about how you think
that cartel works?
'Cause you've written a
little bit about this.
Like when Trump got taken
out after January 6th,
when they took him off Spotify
and Pinterest and Twitter
and YouTube.
You know, it wasn't even
the ones where he was.
It's like okay now he can't
listen to music anymore either.
We're just gonna take
him out of everything.
That they operate
sort of as a cartel.
They just wait for
the first mover
and then everybody
sort of in a minute
does the exact same thing.
Well so Jack Dorsey
actually explained it.
He wrote a Tweet storm
in which he needed,
felt the need to
defend their action
to permanently deplatform Trump.
- Well you had a funny,
you had a funny comment
on what he said.
Because it's like,
he does these things
and then he suddenly
feels very emotional
about what he's done and then
he opens up about everything.
- They make these
kneejerk decisions
that are just like a
violent reaction to it
and then because they don't,
they have a blindspot with
respect to their you know,
their partisan biases
and then they realize,
oh wait a second we
just did something
that is a big deal
and then he comes out
and then gets very introspective
and tries to explain it.
At least he tries to explain it,
that makes Jack my
favorite oligarch.
But what he said is
that when we, Twitter,
decided to ban Trump.
We didn't think it
was that big a deal
because there were
other places he could go
to basically get his
free speech right.
And then all these other
companies did the same thing.
And he's right, if
only one company
were to you know, deplatform you
it might not be that big a deal
but when all of them are
doing it at the same time,
they're acting as
effectively a speech cartel.
Now what Jack said is that they,
that all of us, you
know didn't collude
to make these decisions but
we emboldened each other.
That was his word is embolden.
It sounds a lot to me,
what we would call signaling
in the anti-trust law
where you have a
bunch of companies
that normally compete
with each other
and therefore are trying to
make different decisions,
not all trying to get
to the same decision.
They're trying to
compete with each other,
but signaling occurs when
one company does something
and then you know, all the
other companies follow suit.
And that's basically
what's happening is that,
is that with each
incremental company
that decides to ban
Trump or whoever,
the pressure builds on
all the rest of them
to do the same thing.
Otherwise they'll be
subject to you know,
letterwritting
campaigns and boy,
and all that kind of stuff.
And so, you know,
whether they're actively
colluding or not
or whether it's merely
just the signaling,
you have the same effect
which is a cartel.
- So would you break them up?
I mean would you use
the force of government
to break up some of these
companies at this point?
- I would seriously look at it
because I think they
are too powerful
but I don't think it's gonna
solve the speech problem
for this reason.
Imagine that Google
is busted up into,
you know we have
kind of Google Search
and then YouTube becomes
its own property.
You know, maybe there's
like a third division
for enterprise.
Well I mean YouTube is the one
that we sort of care about.
It's, we're not gonna
divide that property up.
It's still gonna be run.
It'll just have a
different cap table,
it's gonna have the
same exact gives.
They all drink from the same
sort of monocultural fountain,
they all have the
same ideological
commitments and biases.
They're subject to most
of the same pressures.
So I don't know that if
you effectively increase
the size of speech cartel from
five members, to 10 members.
I don't know that that
by itself does anything.
I think what we need and I'm
not expecting to get this
from Congress any time soon is,
some sort of common
carrier obligations
imposed on these
big tech monopolies.
This is a proposal that
came from Richard Epstein
who's a Professor at the
University of Chicago.
Basically what he says is look,
if you're a gigantic
monopoly, you're a utility.
You can't deny a service to
somebody based on their creed.
You know that's the
non-discrimination
rule that we need.
Imagine if you know, like
a common carrier would be
something like a railroad.
Where it's a natural monopoly.
Imagine if in the days of
the Lincoln-Douglas debates,
you know they got around
the country by train.
Imagine if I don't
know, some oligarch,
Cornelius Vanderbilt
or something said,
you know Mr. Lincoln, I
don't like your point of view
in this debate.
I'm gonna deny you service,
I don't want you to be
able to express your views.
Well there's no way that we
would've let that happen.
We wouldn't let somebody,
we wouldn't let monopolies
be that powerful where
they can deny service
to essential facilities to
people based on their creed
and that basically is the
legislative fix here I think.
More than doing something
like repealing Section 230
which I think would hurt
a lot of small innovators.
- Right.
- So yeah,
but look you know, I'm
not expecting to get that
in the next two years
or even four years, so.
- I'm guessing generally
speaking though
you'd rather have
technological solutions to this
than governmental solutions.
I would but, but I don't know
that we're gonna get a
technological solution
because I do think that you
know, monopolies are real.
Part of what I do as an investor
is try and invest in the
next set of monopolies
and you know, you know that's
what Peter's whole book.
- Yeah.
- "Zero to One" is about
is there's two
kinds of companies.
- Right there,
it's right there.
- On the shelf.
Yeah, I mean there's two
kinds of companies right?
There's monopolies
and commodities.
You wanna be a monopoly.
Well monopolies have
incredible market power.
I think it was fine
when those monopolies
were lawfully gained and weren't
trying to use their power
to put their thumb on the
scale of American democracy
and you know it
wasn't that long ago
that these big tech
companies would state
their commitment to neutrality.
I mean Mark Zuckerberg gave,
I think a very good speech
just a few years ago, in 2018.
In which he said that,
he said social networks
were the fifth estate.
You know that the traditional
media historically
was the fourth estate.
I think one through
three were like,
I don't know they go back
to Europe or something
like the nobility
and the peasants
or something.
- It's the people, yeah yeah.
- The people yeah yeah yeah.
Anyway the fourth estate
is traditional media.
What Zuckerberg said
is that social networks
were the fifth estate and
that they posed a threat
to the people in power just
like the fourth estate did
and therefore it
needed to be protected.
And I think he's right
about that and they,
the sad thing is that
he has felt the need
to kind of move
off that position
and engage in this
sort of censorship.
He's, you know.
- When you see these guys have
to go in front of Congress,
when you see Jack or Zuckerberg.
I don't know if you
know them personally,
you know probably at least
somewhere in the circles
they're somewhat close.
But when you see them have
to basically be arguing
with people who have
so little understanding
of what the real issues
are, any of that stuff.
Does it just like drive
you crazy to see it?
- It's a little
painful you know,
because the people doing
the questioning by and large
don't have the knowledge to,
or ability to kind of
interrogate these CEOs
the way that they should
but some of them do.
You know there have been
some interesting moments
where these CEOs get questions
and sort of dressed down.
I mean there's a lot of theater,
it's very performative.
There's a lot of grandstanding.
I mean, I don't really
know how much progress
gets made in these hearings.
But the point of
it I think is valid
which is you have
these, a handful
of tech oligarchs who now
control the public square
and they have
appropriated to themselves
a vast power to
decide who has access
and which views have access
and which views they're
gonna silence and censor
and basically ghost.
And you know, and no one
elected them to have that power
and I think we should be
rightly concerned about that
and I think we should
question them about
how they are
wielding that power.
- How much of an escalation
do you think it was
when Parler got nuked by Amazon?
Because that was
completely different,
taking away servers
than you know,
taking away speech of
an individual person.
- Yeah, I mean it
was an escalation
because you had not just
you know, one person,
Trump or his supporters
being ghosted or deplatformed
but you had 16 million Parler
users or whatever it is.
99.9% of whom never
did anything wrong.
You know and that
was a diminishment
of their free speech rights.
It was also I think unjustified,
if the justification for
that was that Parler was used
in the planning of the
events of January 6th,
it was clearly a scapegoating
because we now have,
FBI charging documents
have come out.
- Yeah.
- They've filed, 226 cases.
The social networking site
that was used 10x more
than all the others
was Facebook.
You know Parler was used
one-tenth of the amount
that Facebook was but
Parler was you know,
was sort of an
easy, an easy target
to sort of scapegoat for that.
- Is that purely because of,
the sort of the cartel mindset
that you were discussing before?
Like there's certain,
there's however many people
or companies are
involved in the cartel
and here's just this new guy.
So it's like, well
they are competition,
there are 21 million
people over there.
May as well just
take them out right?
- Yeah, I mean it's, yeah I
think they're an easy target.
I think Facebook clearly
was eager to deflect blame
onto Parler.
There was actually a
pretty good article
in The Washington
Post about that.
You know calling
Facebook out on that,
pointing to the fact that
they had a lot more of this
problematic content
than Parler did.
But yeah I mean it's an easy way
for these big tech
companies to show
that they're doing something
to control you know,
disinformation or whatever
the powers that be now,
you know are concerned about.
Again I think this all goes
back to the fact that these,
the big tech companies
are very worried
about getting
broken up right now.
They don't wanna get busted up
and so they're looking to
curry favor with you know,
the current administration
in Washington.
- So I can hear all my
pure libertarian fans
in the back of my
head going okay,
you guys are talking too
much about government
and antitrust and regulation
and breaking them up
and all that stuff
when you should be talking
about decentralization
and crypto and everything else.
Do you think there are
enough answers there?
Basically to solve
a lot of this stuff.
- Not in the nearterm.
I mean, I'm a fan of a lot
of those crypto projects
but they are very much projects.
I would like to be able
to call them companies,
some of them I
guess are companies
but they're still at
a super early stage.
You know, we're still building
out poor infrastructure
of these blockchain platforms.
To my knowledge there has not
been a breakout application
built on top of any of these
sort of crypto platforms
except if you wanna you know,
except for Bitcoin and then
DeFi or decentralized finance.
Basically financial speculation.
I think we're a long
way off from you know,
being able to run
truly decentralized,
say speech apps with
billions of users.
You know that seems to me,
years off if not decades
and I'm not really willing
to kind of wait that long
to kind of have the
First Amendment back.
- Yeah and by the way,
that creates a whole host
of other problems right
because then you
could put all sorts
of horrible stuff on
there and once it's there,
it's there and then
you got a whole bunch
of other problems.
- Yeah it's not clear exact,
I mean yeah you need to
have some sort of regulation
of these sites and you know
it's not that I want there to be
anything goes.
I just would prefer
to put my faith
in a venerable external standard
like First Amendment
case law than to give
all this power to
these unelected,
you know oligarchs to
make these decisions about
who gets to participate
in American democracy.
- Yeah so let's shift
a little to lockdowns
and generally what's
happened in the last year
because basically from almost
the day we're posting this,
it was pretty much a
year ago right now,
two weeks to flatten the curve.
Now it's a year
later and people,
you know Biden's double-masking
and you know California,
you still can't go
to indoor restaurants
or go to the gym and
I guess we're gonna
partially open on April
1st or something like that
but so much of this does
seem attached to big tech
because they're letting
you say certain things
about lockdowns and not
letting you say certain things.
Is your belief that
there was just no science
behind the lockdowns
at all at any point?
- Well I guess at the
very beginning of COVID,
we didn't exactly know.
So I don't fault
anyone too much for
the decisions that
were made to lockdown
back in March or April.
We simply didn't know,
as you all recall
I mean we were seeing
what was happening Italy,
the hospitals were
completely overrun
and so this idea of you
know, of locking things down
to buy time so that our medical
system didn't get overrun.
I could understand the
argument but I think by this,
by last summer it was
becoming pretty clear
that lockdowns had an
enormous cost to them
and a very unclear benefit
and I think as the
year progressed,
we had more and more
data around this.
Certainly I think by the fall,
anyone who was paying
attention to that data
would've, you know, should've
been against lockdowns.
I think even by May, I was
tweeting that the right policy
was to go all in on masks
and to not do lockdowns.
So I mean, I think the data
was clear even by then.
- So what do you
think was going on?
I mean in the mind,
we'll get to California more
specifically but generally,
in the mind of Gavin Newsom,
in the mind of Gretchen Whitmer,
in the mind of Andrew Cuomo.
These people that
you know, in essence,
destroyed their states
in a lot of ways
versus Texas and scary Florida.
Like what do you think
they were thinking?
Because I can't find
any science anywhere.
I get what you're saying, yeah.
For a couple weeks
you could try it
and there was this unsure
moment and all that
but then after that.
- Yeah I mean, I don't know
exactly why they thought
the political calculus,
it would benefit them
to have this extreme
lockdown policy
but I think there was sort
of a collective failure
of elite thinking on COVID and
really on many other issues
and really, you have to
go back to the WHO getting
just about everything wrong.
- Yep.
- From the beginning.
First you know, all the
back in January saying
that it wasn't clear that there
was human to human contact
and then when it was
clear that there was,
they greatly exaggerated
the case fatality rate
by claiming that there weren't
a lot of asymptomatic cases.
You know, we would later learn
that there was a huge number
of asymptomatic cases
and therefore we should,
you know the infection
fatality rate
was more like one tenth
the case fatality rate
but they got that wrong
and sort of miseducated us
and then that led to us
thinking that the virus
would be even more
severe than it was.
You know, then they
were wrong about masks
and so was Fauci and the CDC.
I mean I wrote a blog
post in early April
saying that masks
should be the policy.
I thought that was, that
was the type of thing
that was low cost high benefit
and the type of thing we
should be doing, not lockdowns.
And then you know, they
got lockdowns wrong
and then they reversed
course on that
And so there's just been like,
systematically I think
the health establishment
just seems they've gotten
everything wrong here.
And it kind of, I mean
just to tie it back
to the censorship thing.
It shows how ridiculous it
is to maintain this position
that we can censor based
on what experts tell us
as YouTube has been doing.
You know YouTube has been
censoring COVID videos
that have been put up that
they say contradict the WHO.
Apparently without irony
because no one has contradicted
the WHO more than
the WHO itself.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- But this idea that we
can simply rely on experts,
I think that, I mean
it has to be that the,
that has to be one of the
big takeaways of COVID
is that we cannot
rely on these experts.
They're just wrong way too
often and even you know,
Fauci today the guidance
we're getting today
is far too
conservative you know?
Fauci recently said that
we might have to wear masks
until 2022.
Well, why?
I mean you know, are you saying
that vaccines don't work?
Because it seems to
me that the messaging
we're getting now is
effectively antivax.
I mean if the vaccines worked.
- Right, they've all
become antivaxxers yeah.
- Yeah, if the vaccines
work and Biden has now said
that every American adult
can get one by end of May,
why would we need any more
restrictions after Memorial Day?
And so I was in favor of
a mask policy early on
but I do not support
having a mask policy
once vaccines are
available, why?
- So you guys were just talking
about zeroism on the show
and that, it's a
perfect segue for that.
So can you explain that?
- Yeah, so Jonathan Chait
actually came up with it.
You know he's a writer for the,
I guess.
- New Yorker or?
I always forget if it's New
Yorker or New York Magazine.
- I think it's a magazine.
- Okay.
- Yeah I don't think, I think,
I think he's probably, I
don't think he's red pilled,
I think he's pretty liberal
but he's pretty liberal.
- He might have called
me racist once or
twice in a tweet.
- Okay, well he
wrote one good column
where he coins this term zeroism
and what it basically
is is a refusal
to deal with COVID according
to cost benefit analysis
and to insist that even one
case of COVID is unacceptable
because somebody can die
and therefore we need to
have a policy of stamping out
every last case of COVID.
That's zeroism.
The problem with zeroism
is that we're never
gonna get rid of COVID.
I mean there are always gonna be
a smattering of cases somewhere.
It's a seasonal illness,
it's gonna return
and the problem is that
if every time it returns,
we now have the justification
for the politicians
to you know, engage in all
these emergency measures,
it gives them
extraordinary powers.
So yeah,
that's the thing that I
think needs to be challenged
and look at how zeroism
is being used right now.
I mean obviously it
was used to justify
the continuation of lockdowns
far beyond what was necessary.
It's being used today
to keep schools closed.
You know you have the
education unions saying that
even after they're vaccinated,
if there are any cases
of community spread for,
if there's even one
case of community spread
in a two-week period, they
will not go back to school.
I mean this is a recipe for
keeping schools closed forever.
You had our District
Attorney in San Francisco
use COVID as the excuse to
empty out all the jails.
You had Gavin Newsom
use COVID as the excuse
for billions of dollars
of no bid contracts
to his political
supporters and so you know,
you have this suspending of
normal operating procedure
of the way that government works
and if we're gonna
suspend it every time
there's one COVID case,
well that's not gonna work.
- Are you worried though
that that is the net effect
of this thing?
That they pushed us for a year
and they, whoever they are.
But you know, in
effect the system.
So boy, we can really get people
to destroy their own lives
and not see their
family and not travel
and yet they'll do it in
some places like Florida
but we can get people in
California to act like sheep
and there's almost no pushback.
So why not keep pushing?
- Well I think there's
a lot of pushback now.
I mean, look I think
there are a lot of people
who are frightened of COVID
and there will be some
PTSD about it but,
I think that you know,
we're seeing now with
the Newsom recall,
that I think people
are very upset
about the restrictions and
the, the hypocrisy of it.
The fact that Newsom was
going to French Laundry
and you know, even during the
time when was doubling down
on lockdowns and telling people
they couldn't go to the beach,
which I mean that makes no sense
because there's been
no real outdoor spread.
So you had that, he was
sending his own kids
to private school when you know,
the public schools were still
closed and still are closed.
So I think people are
pretty riled up by this
and I do expect that
people will wanna go back
to the way things were
pre-COVID very, very quickly
but I think the
battle to be joined
over the next few months is
the battle against zeroism
and I expect that
we'll win that battle.
I expect that if Newsom sticks
to the zeroist position,
he will be defeated.
I mean the recall
election will be in,
I think around August.
I think every American
who wants a vaccine
will be able to get one in May
and so I think to the extent
that California still has
all these restrictions,
I think every week
pressure's gonna build,
people are gonna in California
look and say well wait,
none of these other states
are doing this stuff.
Why are we still restricted?
- Yeah are you worried though?
Are you worried though that
basically every week from now
till the election he's
gonna open up more and more
and we'll just kind
of forget right?
'Cause we all have
short memories
and even though we've got
the two million signatures,
I know you're bullish
on the recall.
That we'll just kind of forget.
- Well I think Newsom has
already moved to the center
because of recall.
I mean there was
a, there was this,
he was suspicious
that he, he reopened.
That he ended lockdowns for,
at least a big chunk
of the lockdowns
right when the recall
passed a million signatures.
So I think the recall has
been creating pressure
on him to do the right thing.
I mean I think that's a
good thing that, that it's,
that even if the recall
doesn't ultimately pass,
I still think it's a good
thing that it's reminding
the politicians that
they worked for us and,
and for them not to forget that.
- Yeah, before we move on to
your fair city of San Francisco
it just, it just hit me.
Jonathan Chait didn't
call me racist,
he did go after me for
being a small businessman
because I said I had like four,
I said I had several
employees and he felt
that that wasn't enough to be
able to comment on economics
or something to that effect.
Anyway, it wasn't a racist
so I wanna clear that up.
But all right, let's talk
about San Francisco.
- Yeah.
- Because you're not
happy with what's going on
in San Francisco and I've
been there a couple times
in the last couple years.
And I mean, it's
kind of disgusting
the amount of
homelessness, the drug use.
Like it's pretty, you
know there's an app
to track where human poop is.
How much worse does it get
in a Western society city?
- It's become totally dystopian
and a lot of people are leaving.
Like huge numbers of
people left during COVID.
I don't even think we know
how many people have left.
I guess we'll find out after
COVID and everything reopens,
exactly you know, how
damaged this city has become
but it has become a huge
problem and you know,
homelessness is out of control,
crime is out of control.
The city's budget is
completely mismanaged.
They were due for a
giant budgetary shortfall
but they're gonna be saved
by the $1.9 trillion bill
that's coming out of Washington.
So we'll defer that day
of reckoning for.
- Yeah, yeah.
- For another day get the
city is squandering money.
It was recently revealed
that they spend $16 million
providing 260 tents
for homeless people.
So there's a cost
of $61,000 per tent.
I mean obviously.
- You're saying
that's not capital-efficient,
is that what you're telling me?
- Yeah and I think, I
mean I've heard a number
that the city on the whole,
if you look at all
the homeless services
spends about $330,000 per
year per homeless person.
So I mean that's
just like staggering.
- So can you explain
why people seem to be,
maybe it's a California
thing, it's the nice weather,
I don't know.
That they can't seem to
connect the bad policies
and all of the spending with
then the stuff on the ground.
They can't understand that
the more they put these people
into power, the more that
the homelessness expands,
that the drug use expands.
That schools get worse, that
you know, businesses leave,
that house prices get higher.
All of these things and then
they somehow always blame
the Republicans even
though there's virtually
no Republicans in
power in the state.
- All right, yeah exactly.
Well and that's part
of the problem is
we haven't, for whatever reason
we haven't had a
functional Republican party
in a long time in California
and so therefore there
hasn't really been a choice
and we've been living
under a one party state
and one party states
generally don't go very well.
So yeah but look, are
voters waking up to this?
I think so, I mean you know,
judging by my friends
on the Pod, they're all,
they're all getting red pilled
to one degree or another.
I'm not saying they're ready
to vote Republican but I
think they're pretty upset
and they're looking for a
different kind of Democrat,
let's put it that way.
- Listen, the line
I've been using.
It's basically you're
woke or conservative.
It doesn't mean
you're a conservative
like a card-carrying member
of the Republican party.
I don't consider
myself a Republican
but it's pretty much everyone
versus the woke at the moment
and we gotta set
aside our differences
to clean up some of this stuff.
But you've been
going after your DA,
Chesa Boudin is that it?
- Boudin yeah, Chesa Boudin.
- Chesa Boudin, doesn't
have the cajones
to debate you apparently.
- Well I was trying to
goad him into debate
because yeah, I mean
I'd love to debate him
about what's going
on in San Francisco.
There's a number of
these radical DAs now.
LA has one too, Gascon
who was a previous DA
in San Francisco
who moved down to.
- Yeah thanks for that.
- To LA.
Yeah exactly, so you
should be prepared for,
for what's coming.
They've done a number
of similar things.
They've, I mean first of all,
they've shown no interest
in prosecuting misdemeanors,
so property crimes.
These are just quality of
life crimes that don't,
you know they don't effect,
they don't have victims
is the theory.
Well they do if you
have enough of them
and you can't park a
car in San Francisco
without fear that it's
going to be broken into.
That the, there's now been
a spade of home
invasion burglaries
that are up some astronomical
number every year.
You know there's, and now
there's other kinds of crimes.
We've had a number of
people get killed recently.
I mean very sad
cases where you had,
I mean there have been,
just there's been a
few of these recently.
So on New Year's Eve, there
were two women who were killed.
They were run down by a
driver of a stolen car
who was on drugs
fleeing another crime,
I think a burglary
he had committed.
This, this criminal
Troy McAlister,
he had been arrested five times
in the previous six months.
He had been let go
every single time.
The DA had chosen not to
prosecute charges and in fact,
he was paroled six
months before in a case
where he was in jail awaiting
trial on armed robbery.
He had used a gun
in robbing a store
and that was gonna be his
third strike and the new DA,
Chesa Boudin came in and
pleaded him down to time served
and so you know,
you have a case that
with you know, with New
Year's Eve where you know,
the decisions of this
District Attorney
led directly to the deaths
of these two people.
You had Hana Abe
and Elizabeth Platt.
So anyway, it was you
know, very sad case.
And there's a
bunch of these now.
I mean there's more
and more victims.
- What do you think, I mean
just to give the Devil his due.
What do you think the
DA thinks he's doing?
- Well his agenda is
mass decarceration
and he's talked
a lot about this.
He is the child
of two weather underground
domestic terrorists
who were put in jail for an
armed robbery at Brink's,
heist that went
wrong and ended up,
the people in that
group ended up killing
a couple of police
officers and guards
and so his dad is
still in prison
and he says his oldest memory
is visiting his parents in
prison and that profoundly
shaped his view of politics
and the criminal justice system
and I don't think it's
an exaggeration to say
that his agenda is to release
as many criminals as possible
without real concern
for the new victims
that's gonna create,
the victims of crime
and it's a radical ideology.
I mean Gascon's ideology
is pretty similar.
And some examples are you know,
with Gascon he won't
prosecute three strikes.
Actually his own DA's had to
bring a lawsuit against him.
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
- To get up all the judge,
the judge told him
he had to enforce it.
I don't expect him to put
a lot of effort into it.
He's prohibited
prosecutors from attending,
both Boudin and Gascon
have prohibited prosecutors
from attending parole hearings.
And so there's no one to
stand up in these hearings
for the victims when you know,
we're talking about criminals
who've done you know,
horrible, horrible crimes.
Killings and the victims
groups are up in arms
because they used
to have a prosecutor
go up there and speak for
them and because of that,
we've already had cases
in LA where murderers
have been set free.
Neither one of them will charge
enhancements to sentences
for you know, gang
enhancements, gun enhancements
and I've talked to
prosecutors who,
that's a very important part
of their charging strategy
and so you know, they're
really taking away
all the weapons that prosecutors
have at their disposal
to keep these violent
felons off the street.
And by the way, there's
a really perverse result
that's happened
as well which is,
I don't know if you remember
but several years ago
the voters of California
passed Prop 47 which downgraded
a bunch of property
felonies to misdemeanors
and this was marketed to
all of us as you know,
prisons were overcrowded and
this was excessive punishment.
Well the problem is that,
that these property crimes
like auto theft and
stealing less than $950,
now that they're misdemeanors,
Boudin and Gascon have
absolutely no interest
in prosecuting them.
I don't think the voters of
California would've voted
for Prop 47 if they thought
they were decriminalizing theft
which is effectively
what they did.
And so we now have this
problem where shoplifting
is basically, it just,
we've had Walgreens
has exited San
Francisco because people
would just come in
there with garbage bags
and just load them up.
- We covered it on
my show last week.
10 Walgreens in the San
Francisco Bay Area have closed
and there's video of
just people literally
just one arm, the entire shelf
and what are you gonna do?
- Right I mean look, if you
have a DA who says effectively
that we're not gonna
prosecute that crime,
you've decriminalized
it, you've made it legal.
And so San Francisco
has basically hung a
burglars welcome sign at the
city limits and you know,
so I'm not expecting
the crime stats
to go in the right
direction after this.
So Sacks, there are
people watching this
going what are you two
shmucks doing in California?
Give me something hopeful.
Is there, is there
anything hopeful?
You know okay, so maybe
the recall happens maybe.
- Right.
- But do you see
any real exit for San Francisco.
Like how bad does
it have to get?
How much of that has to
be exported you know,
a little down south
to me here in LA?
Like do you see any hope?
- Well people really are up
in arms about Boudin you know.
I think even, I'd say
even more than Newsom.
There's a recall
underway for Chesa,
there's a recall
underway for Gascon.
In addition to Newsom, heck
there's even a recall underway
for the San Francisco
School Board.
So you know, by the way
I'm supporting all of them
and if there's anybody
that's out there.
- I'm with you.
- Who wants to do, who wants
to do a recall let me know.
If you're willing to put
in the legwork and the time
I'll write a donation
to support you.
So you know, I do
think that you know,
people are up in arms
and they wanna change
and it's not partisan.
You know, the first
thing that you know,
Chesa and these other guys,
what they'd love to make it
about is partisan politics
but look, when
Chesa gets recalled,
the mayor London Breed is
gonna appoint his successor.
That person's
gonna be a Democrat
but it's gonna be a
reasonable Democrat
who just wants to
enforce the law,
do a good job as
District Attorney.
That's all we want,
we're not looking for
some political change.
We just want the laws enforced.
So you know, we shouldn't let
these guys change the subject.
You know this is nothing to
do with partisan politics.
- Yeah all right, that
feels like the right end.
That was sort of hopeful,
that was kind of hopeful.
We just want laws enforced,
that seems sort
of hopeful right?
- Yeah I know, all that we're
really looking for here is,
is civil society to
basically be restored.
We don't have very
high standards.
We just want schools to open,
we want crime to be prosecuted.
You know we want the government
to stop shutting
everything down.
We you know, we want
government contracting
to be done in a transparent way,
that's not just a payoff
to political supporters.
So I guess the
hopeful thing would be
that things are so bad
we don't need a lot to see
a big improvement you know?
We just need to get
to some normality here
and I do think a majority of
voters in the state want this
and so if we can just
marshal this energy
to produce this change,
I think we will get it.
- Real radical stuff.
- If we don't,
if we don't, then I'm
out in Miami more.
- Exactly, real radical stuff,
a return to living
under the law.
How bizarre, all
right well anyone
that wants to get involved
with any kind of recall effort,
it sounds like David Sacks is
willing to write you a check.
So his Twitter is @DavidSacks,
the podcast is The All-In Pod
which you can get anywhere
podcasts are downloadable.
David, I thank you
for doing the show.
- Yeah, great to be here.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about tech
instead of nonstep yelling,
check out our tech playlist
and if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist,
they're right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell.